Ecuador and Qatar have both been caught  up in controversy before the first World  Cup game kicks off when Chile which  didn't qualify alleged Ecuadorian  Defender Byron Castile was born in  Colombia the Ecuador team faced  expulsion and possible replacement by  well Chile questions over the  nationality of players have long loomed  over the Qatari Squad as well in 2004 he  tried to naturalize three Brazilian  players FIFA blocked the move and  tightened naturalization rules today  almost half the team were born outside  Qatar but it's unclear how many were  naturalized in order to qualify for the  team Ecuador's football Authority was  fined a hundred thousand Swiss Francs  for accepting false information about  castile's birthplace but FIFA allowed  them to play Castile won't be playing  but should Qatar win all eyes will be on  the original nationality of the goal  scorers